also they do take pregnancy into account
the safe limit is often based on a tiny
effect in unborn Rats on top of that the
amounts allowed in sunscreens are a
fraction of an amount that still
shouldn't give that tiny effect usually
a hundred times less he says no one can
say with 100 uncertainty what the
effects are over many years which is
true science doesn't really do certainty
scientists won't even say the sun will
definitely rise tomorrow but he forgot
that we also aren't sure mineral
sunscreens are 100 safe or just sun
exposure some of the issues with mineral
sunscreens titanium dark side was just
banned in the EU in food for potential
cancer risk it's a controversial
decision they're looking at it in
sunscreen soon in all sunscreens could
potentially be linked to hair loss they
don't protect as well as chemical
sunscreens there's a lot of stability
problems and they give a white cast plus
a lot of them have SPF boosters these
are modified chemical sunscreens but not
as strictly regulated so less safe than
actual chemical sunscreens there's two
in the sunscreen he recommends yes you
can still avoid chemical sunscreens just
in case but his video is missing a lot
of important context